just days before marking his first year
in office the world's youngest elected
president made light of a gift one meant
to compare him with the cuddly fictional
character Winnie the Pooh
until a few months ago Gabriel boricu
turned 38 last month wasn't laughing as
much
his approval ratings had plummeted
inflation and crime rates were
escalating and a highly controversial
presidential pardon of people connected
to the violent protests against
inequality in 2019 led to the
resignation of his chief of staff and
the Minister of Justice
the overwhelming defeat in a referendum
last September of a progressive new
constitution dealt a harsh blow and was
seen as a rejection of the president
himself
the Constitution was The Matrix of his
program of the generation that brought
borage to power that might have dealt a
knockout punch for any government but
Boris showed extraordinary resilience
and ability to get up and come out
fighting again
now a new perhaps less ambitious draft
Constitution is in the works the economy
is recovering inflation is down
investment is up and so are the
president's approval ratings
we've had difficulties I won't deny it
but I want to tell the whole country
that today I am full of Hope and
optimism
many admire his ability to show
flexibility and make concessions when
his plans aren't working borage is
starting his second year with a cabinet
reshuffled and above all emphasizes
experience his message to Chileans is
that the time for making a diagnosis of
this country's problems is over and that
it's now time to act and perhaps for
that reason as opposed to last year
there are very few Millennials left in
his cabinet
while some more hard line leftists
accuse bodage of betraying his
principles many people we spoke to rated
him highly
I think he's doing a good job it's not
his fault that the conservative
congressmen refused to approve a tax
reform Bill meant to finance social
programs for all of us and he's a first
president to roll up his sleeves right
away to oversee the disaster left by
this year's forest fires
it's too soon to judge the work of the
government in just one year that takes
more time but in general I think he's
good I like his style
it's a political style that some people
are still trying to come to terms with
but like him or not the new Left
president has shown an ability to
maintain stability even in these complex
and polarized times
see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago